le président de la république de la côte
d'ivoire monsieur houphouët boigny était
aujourd'hui à l'hôtel matignon l'hôte du
premier ministre monsieur georges
pompidou après le déjeuner donné en son
honneur il ya nouvel entretien avec le
premier ministre le président ivoirien
entouré dans les journalistes à d'abord
réaffirmé sur l'entière confiance dans
l'évolution des rapports de coopération
établies entre la côte d'ivoire et la
france
tout le proviseur que nous éprouverons à
me retrouver à paris et à reprendre
contact avec
la responsable français notamment avec
le premier ministre
c'est quand tu as connu
je faisais partie du mouvement koné
clairement les jeunes ados gaulle nous
avons fait un large tour d'horizon
qui embrassait bien sûr les rapports
franco ivoirien tout premier lieu
la santé morale de notre pays
d'excellentes je n'ai pas du bois pour
toucher l'eau du bois mais il n'ya pas
que la côte d'ivoire qui nous préoccupe
c'est tout l'ensemble franco-africain
nous sommes tombés d'accord
penser que cette coopération
encore africaine qui a déjà porté ses
fruits et doivent se poursuivre dans
l'amitié et dans la confiance de barils
au avez-vous fait part de vos
appréciations sur la situation dans le
proche orient
je le proche orient
il n'ya pas d'appréciation connaissez
notre position nous voulons la paix dans
ce coin du monde je vous viens de vous
dire que la paix est indivisible et
c'est dans la mesure où on créerait les
conditions qui permettent la paix au
moyen orient qu on servirait le monde